was Castle stressful Castle's stressful  just if not just for the schedule alone  it was an intense schedule five days a  week or six days a week but just five  and sometimes six  and how did you cope with that uh not  well you can look at photos of me during  that time I just get kind of more tired  and Bloated as years ago well how did  you get through it because there's been  moments where I I've seen other actors  or I've seen myself going how am I gonna  get through this yeah how do you I'm  just so tired I'm just so tired I've  never passes and then eventually there's  a light at the end of the tunnel and  then you kind of aim at that and then  when it ends that's the thing it's  finite right and it's not going to last  forever you can make it